hey youtubers is Charlie so we are like
firmly in Marvel summer movie season so
I wanted to do a new Captain America
Civil War video all about Bucky
he got name-drop big time during
Avengers age of Ultron but we really
don't know what he's up to right now we
do know that he will be part of Captain
America's Civil War but as far as far as
we know he's still glitched out just
wandering across the countryside he's in
like Bill Bixby Hulk mode just you know
wandering down the highway during Winter
Soldier he had started to regain his
memory but you know that Hydra would
shock it back out of him but now that he
is free of Hydra
presumably he's starting to remember
everything and it's sticking he's doing
that hero thing where he's like I can't
handle all the emotions of the terrible
things I've done so I'm just gonna
wander off into nowhere I'm gonna have
to reference a couple things from
Avengers age of Ultron so just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen that
movie yet I actually think as of me
doing this video it still hasn't been
released in a few countries which kind
of sucks but here we go
so during Avengers age of Ultron Falcon
shows up you know during through the big
battle and you have that typical scene
where the heroes were the Avengers go
where you been you almost missed all the
fun in Falcon said I've been working a
missing persons case that missing person
is the Winter Soldier he basically did
the same thing at the end of Winter
Soldier that the Hulk did at the end of
age of Ultron I can't handle my emotions
so I'm just gonna take myself out of the
equation I'll have to do like a separate
video about the Hulk at some point I
know there's a bunch of questions about
what he's up to right now he is still on
planet earth for those that are asking
just like the Winter Soldier nobody's in
space but now we need to jump to the
Winter Soldier a comic book I mean it
was like an arc in the Captain America
comics that deals with Bucky's time
after he presumably died you know then
got frozen by the Soviets then unfrozen
to assassinate people all the way up to
present-day the movie changed a whole
lot from the comic book that that's
nothing new but they did a pretty good
job of explaining in montage like all
the big assassinations that the Winter
Soldier was supposed to have done like
JFK but you know in the comic books it's
actually way cooler because Marvel can
do whatever characters they want like
they associate him with the
assassination of Wolverines wife in the
attempted assassination of his son Daken
he paired up with Black Widow early in
her years after graduating from the Red
Room there's all kinds of awesome you
know Marvel push-pull videos to be done
between the movies in the comics I have
like a Doctor Doom Doctor
strange video that I'm gonna probably
gonna do pretty soon too but in the
comics and in the movies
Bucky slowly starts to get his memories
back slowly starts to remember that he
is Captain America's friend although he
still kind of remains something of a
fringe character what I think the movies
are gonna end up doing is is during
Captain America Civil War Bucky will
have a similar arc to what he had in the
Civil War comic book me he's kind of on
the outskirts still trying to run from
his past as the Winter Soldier tried
trying to escape Hydra from capturing
him and using him to their advantage but
also trying to help Captain America
without getting you know directly
involved in like the cap versus Ironman
situation the main storyline of the
movie is gonna be all about this
conflict between cap and Iron Man but
you have all these new villains and all
these new heroes swirling around in the
background you also have this third
party the Winter Soldier
or you know Bucky have we want to think
about him that's not really connected to
any of the big groups
so like the Bucky arc in the movie will
probably like its own small little thing
he's mostly important to the character
development of Steve Rogers too like the
arc of that character specifically this
is really funny thing in movies like age
of Ultron we like the really big Marvel
movies where you have like a bunch of
small movies inside one big movie like
you can make this Captain America
Bucky's storyline its own small movie by
itself but instead of that they're
including it as an arc in Captain
America Civil War the same thing is true
of the black panther character that
they're introducing and the new
spider-man character also being
introduced in Captain America Civil War
a whole bunch of stuff happening inside
that movie just avoiding the biggest
Civil War spoilers for those that
haven't read the comic you know Bucky
tries to help cap by running off with
his shield but he ends up getting
recaptured or captured by Red Skull and
Doctor Faustus to try to brainwash him
again brainwashing is a recurring theme
with the winter soldiers character
eventually he escapes gets recaptured by
shield hates the at a Tony Stark
because of what happened during Civil
War wants to kill him but then Tony
surprises him by telling him that
Captain America wants him to take up the
mantle so this is the beginning of the
Bucky Captain America arc you know until
Steve Rogers eventually takes back the
mantle that happened during the Captain
America reborn storyline the funny thing
about that is that part of that story
served as inspiration for the first
in America movie even though it came
after Civil War in the comics the reason
for that is that it was kind of a
rebooting of the Captain America Steve
Rogers character a good Marvel ever ran
into a situation where they needed to
recast the Steve Rogers character like
Chris Evans didn't want to re-sign his
Marvel contract they would probably use
that reborn storyline Chris Evans right
now is gonna be done with his Marvel
contract after infinity War part 2 but
Kevin Feige did say that a couple of the
Avengers characters had resided there
contracts so they'll continue to be
there avenger characters through phase
four he didn't say which ones but there
at least like three or four that will be
done after infinity War part two like
Chris Hemsworth Chris Evans are like the
two really big ones Marvel is really
good about changing stories to fit with
you know the way their business works so
you know if there's a new Captain
America there they have like 14 or 15
different choices that they could use
Sebastian Stan Bucky just being at the
top of that list that's why I think you
know even if Chris Evans does re-sign
will still see like an alternate Captain
America at some point between Captain
America Civil War and infinity War part
two where like someone briefly picks up
the shield until Steve Rogers takes the
mantle back you know during infinity War
part two you know big big comeback movie
fun fact they've actually been like 15
different characters in the comics that
have been Captain America including
Steve Rogers there's Isiah Bradley first
african-american Captain America William
näslund Jeffrey mace William Burnside
Bob Russo scar Turpin Brosco Simon's
John Walker Sam Wilson that's the Falcon
he's Captain America right now Bucky
Barnes obviously you know key became
Captain America after Civil War Dave
Wickford Daniel cage who's actually the
daughter of Luke Cage and Jessica Jones
she shows up in like this alternate
future timeline so she's like a super
strong Captain America where like the
shield is more of an ornament like she
doesn't need it for protective cover
because her body is super strong it's
really funny there's an alternate
universe version of Scott Summers that
became Captain America for a brief
period and then there's a what-if
storyline where the Punisher became
Captain America like a really stabby
dark version of Captain America
obviously the movies are way simpler
than the comics so the logical choice
for the next cap
if there is going to be a new Captain
America would be Bucky it's just a
really easy Redemption art to put them
on you don't until Steve Rogers is ready
to take the mantle back whether it be
Chris Evans or a new actor and I do feel
like Chris Evans will resign his
contract I feel like the big Marvel
actors you know even though they don't
make a ton of money from these Marvel
movies do get to do a lot of really
inspirational charity work like when
Chris Evans and Chris Pratt did that
special contest during the Superbowl
where they they both dressed up as their
characters and went to a bunch of
children's hospitals it's stuff like
that that I think will keep these guys
playing those characters just because
you know they're able to do a lot of
charity work you know even if they don't
know a lot of money typically most of
the money that they make are from the
other films that they make because they
become famous during these Marvel movies
so you get paid a ton of money by other
Studios to do their big blockbuster
movies like Chris Pratt Jurassic Park
probably getting paid way more for that
movie then he got paid for guardians of
the galaxy
so speaking of like you know crazy movie
- comic book interaction I still need to
do a Baron Zemo video just because he's
you know rumored to be part of Captain
America Civil War but he's really
interesting comic book character that
straddles the line between you know
mystic arts and science you know via
Hydra I also kind of want to do a Doctor
Doom Doctor Strange video along those
lines so I might roll all those
characters into into the same video so
be sure to subscribe to get that I'll
probably post it next week you know four
things are a little slow this week I'll
post it later this week I just I feel
like Marvel's dipping its toes into
movie characters that straddle the line
between science and magic and in the
Marvel Universe the best example that is
Doctor Doom problem is Marvel can't use
them in the movies so I feel like Baron
Zemo is like an easy stand-in for that
along those lines you know if you
haven't been reading The Secret Wars
comic book beauty - it's a lot of fun
instead of the usual you know
grandstanding Doctor Doom it goes
full-blown god-emperor doom this summer
is like the best time to be a dr. doom
fan I'm also working on a flash mirror
master video that I'll probably post
later tonight but well you guys wait for
that you can click here to learn about
the rest of the cast in Captain America
Civil War there's a lot of people and
you can click here to learn all about
Hank Pimm's history in the comics
don't forget ant-man is coming up next
month so thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight everybody
let's high-five
you